[Music]
here's the ending of part 1 in case for
some reason you decided you know what I
think it's about time I went to my first
Harry Potter movie when the Deathly
Hallows Part 2 came out it rehashes last
movies ending like we're not already
pressed for time here 22 seconds of logo
magical military marking formations
finally the conclusion to the half movie
you watch nearly a goddamn year ago
Harry and friends forget to etch Davey's
ex machina accomplishments on his
tombstone yep they can use magic to
engrave the headstone but not to bring
Dobby back to life oh well Dobby they're
holding the Goblin prisoner in this room
but probably didn't even bother to
explain to him how the for seashells
work it's complicated every time someone
asks Harry how he got his sword he tells
them it's too long or too complicated a
story to tell but all he has to say is a
hologram dear showed me the way and in
the magic world I guess that would earn
a respectful not so it presented itself
to us we're still debating why that
bastard sword waited so damn long and
our moment of need we camp for days what
the contracts Hollow and fought a snake
and camped another day before it finally
said a name also is this a good time to
ask why this sword was ever created in
the first place
Godric Gryffindor actually said to
himself magic magic everywhere but I
need a sword to kill some fools
Oh balls professor as I understand it
he's now headmaster either you don't
know that person's name is Snape or you
just did a horrible job protecting his
identity in the last movie Bellatrix
went crazy trying to figure out how they
got into her vault which leads Harry to
make a somewhat ridiculous leap that
there might be a Horcrux in there too
this is all because Snape put a fake
Sword of Gryffindor in revolt for
reasons I will never begin to understand
sure Voldemort might have said we need
to get that sword
it has basilisk venom wanted after the
events of Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets but he is shown time and time
again that he's not that forward
thinking or careful or observant was is
he not still perhaps not if you want it
from him now in the eighth movie the
series finally explains why using other
people's wands can be difficult I still
don't know why Harry was able to use
Hermione's wand in the last movie or why
people can't get new ones if there's
break or why it's sometimes they need
wands and sometimes they don't and
what do you know about the deathly
hallows roll credits you know one exists
you told him about it part ones pronoun
game usage set a world record and part
two drives it into overkill I don't even
care if he can refer to only one person
it's true what you say and he has the
Elder Wand afraid really don't stand a
chance
the guy who just said you have to win
the wand in order to control it believes
all the more can control the older one
after stealing it from a dead Dumbledore
where in the fuck did they manage to get
a Bellatrix heir was it on Hermione's
clothes after Bellatrix tortured her was
his convenient issue or they saying
hermione had the wherewithal to take one
from her before they went into that
dobby portal haha because Hermione's
never worn heels before or something
not sure why tripping is funny or
logical here but I guess we need some
way to show that they might get caught
as Impostors would you mind presenting
your wand and why should I do that
instead of just presenting Bellatrix is
real wand which they have they go with
that these aren't the droids you're
looking for plan which granite works but
still overcomplicated plan is over
complicated
very well madam Lestrange or in the
magic world where people can change and
other people and do all sorts of magic
spells so it's weird that this goblin
behind the guy who just got roofied
decides wow this story seemed like both
to me and my boss demanded the wand and
completely changed his mind for no
reason but they don't pay me enough to
argue also wouldn't that mind-control
spell come in handy a number of times
previous to and succeeding this occasion
3d justification the facedown full horse
is away all enchantments but only after
the spectacular 3d rollercoaster ride
huh Smaug wait despite the fact that the
thief's downfalls stop the cart and dump
them out it doesn't lock them in some
magical walls some sort multiply and
that's their last defense thing
multiplication everything you touch will
multiply but Harry will still somehow
make this climb up all the Bulls also
why isn't this damn thing behind a
series of magical curses and defenses
you know all those protection charms
they keep putting around themselves in
part one one of those plus some murdery
ones I have one a buried somewhere not
here Harry Potter mini villains use the
Hobbit school of hiding behind pillars
to protect against extremely intense
dragon heat method which works amazingly
well in both movies dragon is for some
reason totally okay with these three
little humans riding his spikes and none
of the muggles saw the obvious dragon
destroying groups and flying over London
because muggles are the least thing
observing species on the planet in these
movies now and that dragon was never to
be seen again I heard it became an
accountant it married that other
forgotten dragon from Goblet of Fire
right here flashback he knows you know
you're still you-know-who a huh there's
more one of them's a Hogwarts harry's
connection to Voldemort is actually a
cool plot point that has been developed
well over the series but only just now
does it tell Harry where the next
Horcruxes because they had no idea where
to go after the bank heist what if any
of our plans ever actually worked like
100 percent of the time I'm fine with
two naked male torsos and it's smart
because those clothes are wet they could
catch pneumonia there's not a spell for
that so I'm kind of sending the fact
that Hermione is not smart in this scene
also how are their dry clothes from
anywhere that they can change into after
being submerged furthermore why isn't
there a magic spell to dry clothes and
Dobby with the amazing timing of a plot
convenience I might add what makes you
think you can believe anything my
brother told you and all the time you
knew did he ever mention
my name right not mentioning a seemingly
creepy brother's name totally means
everything Dumbledore ever said is now
suspect gotcha
wherever you center don't say no because
this is an important journey I just
called a suicide mission I want to keep
this spoiler free that's because it
never existed till now so a magical
painting of Dumbledore sister just dug a
secret tunnel to Hogwarts that I am
totally down with and have no questions
about what I am concerned with his why
this kind of magic couldn't have been
used in so many other situations before
this but I guess I should just expect it
by now sure the guy who's supposed to be
incognito right now let's cheer in clap
when he shows up that can't possibly
raise suspicion it seems despite your
exhaustive defensive strategies you set
up a bit of a security problem
headmaster because as you see we managed
to sneak in all the Weasleys again
here's some awesome magic being
conducted without a wand wands are
important then they aren't depending on
what the story needs lead mr. Parkinson
and the rest of Slytherin house from the
hall exactly where is it I'll be leading
him to mob the dungeons would do patriot
act also this goes back to what we said
a long time ago about Slytherin house if
you're picked by the sorting had to go
there you're basically being told you're
an evil person and in this case it's all
the Slytherin do what you have to do
I'll secure the castle I'll make sure
none of those painting assholes can take
a secret tunnel in here like Dumbledore
dead sister did me hong quartz had a
statue army this whole time and never
once used it all the times Hogwarts
needed protecting was forward to use
that spell seems to me you've had plenty
of opportunities freaking gift-wrap for
you in the previous seven movies but
whatever each one of these professors
has to shoot their own protection spells
into the air because their magic only
covers a five foot by five foot square
area and all sorts of Baltimore's can
come in if you don't get good coverage
also super-powerful looking force field
spell makes its first appearance in the
final battle despite appearing to be the
perfect spell for several previous
perilous incidents production charm sex
Kenneth Donald isn't my ghostly
girlfriend or having my ghost babies are
allowing me to play Egon Spengler with
my fully functional proton pack in the
sea
that's racist Tom Riddle but he lied
back then why would you give the diadem
to anyone who would want to destroy it
it didn't have Voldemort's soul in it it
was just a freakin diet he just borrowed
it yeah so why did you give it to him
again I'll give him a perfectly good
diadem question mark profits
I guess Ron can speak Parseltongue
because finale
alright so please sleep you Ron makes
Hermione take on the basilisk tooth
stabbing duties because that's how a man
behaves with the flooding happen
anywhere they decided to stab the
Horcrux or is it just because they're in
the Chamber of Secrets and if the water
isn't going to drown anyone what's the
goddamn point yep totally feels natural
when you Ram it down our throats like
this
it's weird no one ever thought of a mass
killing curse like a plural Avada
Kedavra for situations just like this
movie thinks we don't know Neville's
survived the fall and movie is sadly
mistaken
trolls stone soldiers excitement
Kingsley spell is exactly the same
bullshit that turned Jessica Alba and
the others into the Fantastic Four
[Music]
pretty what was the it ron was referring
to was it Harry Potter because Harry
Potter was easiest to find on this map
not Harry Potter what it were they
looking for surely they didn't expect to
find the diadem on the map I guess I'm
confused
oh well also sending the marauders map
here for not showing Draco or his
buddies anywhere when they are
definitely behind Harry Potter at this
moment so I guess Harry really needed to
get into this rumor requirement but then
so did these assholes following it
whatever I guess but it seems like the
rumor of requirements just taking all
comers at this point why didn't you tell
her who's her
if I do him you me make love to then
that's probably okay in Voldemort's book
but you cannot kill Harry Potter because
of the stupid rule that only he can kill
him so this scene just got robbed of its
tension how does it feel
legitimately surprised there's not a
spell for quickly climbing chair piles
oh look booms right when we need them if
we die I'm gonna kill you cliche the
power of three flaming Voldemort heads
cannot penetrate the Room of Requirement
doors about now Voldemort is wondering
why you didn't stick a few Horcruxes in
other countries or in random places with
no meaning our movie theaters playing
Mars Needs Moms so they would never be
found I need to keep this as well didn't
talk to his snake so damn much Harry
would never figured out how important it
was also why not send a Guinea to France
while they attack Hogwarts it could curl
up at the French Open and taken into da
match while its master wins life I guess
remember in order of the Phoenix when
Voldemort was planting false visions in
Harry's mind so he could set a trap what
happened to that we don't know when he
spells that work against giants run the
Battle of Hogwarts being relegated to a
third tier action scene something we see
flashes of as the characters were
following run past it is really fucking
annoying incredible timing is Aberforth
shows up at the exact same place as
Harry Wright at the moment a flying ton
of Dementor show up movie series that
has shown us that magical dudes can
often tell when they're being
eavesdropped on especially by students
decides I can't think of any other way
to convey this exposition between two of
the most powerful Wizards ever while you
live the older one can truly be mine
we've seen Voldemort doing all sorts of
magic with this wand but because it's
resisting him he decides to kill Snape
believing that the wand will truly be
his after that but then what what is it
that he can't do right now that he could
do with a more compliant wand this is
the more power problem at work because
the movie can't sufficiently tell us
what more power means and here no
problem killing Snape with the same
troublesome lon he didn't even have to
say a spell funny story so I went to the
bathroom and went into a completely
different auditorium showing some movie
where some dudes tears were suddenly
magical and being harvested but oh wait
this is the right auditorium man if only
I knew which Weasley this was I might
feel a bit bad about this
Voldemort gave me an ultimatum to fight
him but I think I have some time to
check out Snape steers so I can find out
he was a good guy after all
geez how many tears did he get them
Snape I think he got like maybe one tear
or two but not a whole 5-hour energy
drink full Snape steers posthumously
absolve him of any wrongdoing so the
audience I mean Harry won't hate it
sorting had is addictive Snape's love
life Snape said Harry had his mom's eyes
but his her blue and hers are pretty
brown maybe he was talking about shape
or prescription
let's get married later on rub Snape's
face in our love
Voldemort based his plot to kill Harry
Potter on this witch's prophecy and as
likable and she is she's awful at
predicting and it's incredible he took
her so seriously he has her eyes all of
a sudden they won't come a time when a
Harry Potter must be told something but
you must wait until Voldemort is that
his most vulnerable
why the fuck also I don't know how Snape
was supposed to know when Voldemort was
at his most vulnerable but what was he
waiting for
he didn't even bother to put memory
tears in a special jar just in case he
died before he could get to him luckily
Harry was around to witness the attack
and he didn't die too fast
a part of Voldemort soul that's itself
under the only living thing it could
find what since when does Horcrux
manufacturing work that way every single
Horcrux Harry is destroyed has been
inside some sort of object not a living
thing and doesn't Baltimore actually
have to do something with his soul to
make a Horcrux why did it try to make a
Horcrux immediately after he killed Lily
also I don't know if we sent it before
probably did but it the spell Lily put
on Harry should have been cast on every
damn person at Hogwarts before this
battle started this flashback is going
on five minutes at this point the power
of boners turns your Patronus into the
woman you love spit on us also that
explains how Harry ended up finding the
Sword of Gryffindor but all the stuff we
said about that still stands there's no
reason why that took so long there's a
reason I can hear them dog whistles the
whole crux oh and hung words is trashed
I guess I should feel lost but I know
they'll use the same spell that fixed
the Weasleys house so I guess the
destruction isn't anything I should
really care about snitch tasting man
good thing you never lost that snitch
during all the Bulls this movie in the
last where he could have and should have
lost that snitch you've been so brave
actually that's all he's been all eight
movies bravery is really the only heroic
characteristic he's displayed all the
solutions have either been found by his
friends are handed to him on an ex
machina platter
well that's creepy so you saw me
masturbate I guess it would've caused
some serious spirit world marital
discord if Snape had been allowed into
Harry's people who loved him reunion and
this guy has been mega patient he's
waited through an entire ten minutes
napes tears tell the whole story
sequence plus a harry touches base with
his ghost relative scene and he's just
standing here
deleted scene includes Voldemort
skipping rocks across a pond waiting for
Harry to show up no sign of him live
Lord what do you mean he's been talking
to his ghost loved ones for like five
minutes how have you not seen him and he
shows up like 30 seconds after the dude
says this Oh better question what are
you doing here alive help prisoner
unlike all the other fools they just
simply kill why is this asshole not
2,000 miles away by now
it's a times like these when I wonder
why Voldemort doesn't do that throat
slitting thing he did to Snape seems
like he'd be unable to recover from that
although to be fair Harry shouldn't be
able to recover from this either so it
goes this is basically the matrix ending
hero has to die to save the world or the
Iron Giant ending or the big year of six
ending or the Jesus ending Wow magic
heaven looks fake --is-- speaking of
magic heaven
do they have their own separate heaven
from the muggle one because if so even
gods resist in this universe well that's
been disgusting makes you wonder what's
going on in magic hell well it's a good
thing that when Harry went to limbo
Dumbledore could be there to share his
experience so he could tell Harry the
choice he has so what is that something
we all neither allow Oh where would you
say the way-out discount Cloud City you
or the Horcrux he never meant to make
Harry those crazy accidental Horcruxes
have to go back haven't I oh that's up
to you so Harry was a Horcrux and
Baltimore killed Harry which means that
puts him in limbo somehow it's not
really explained all that well so sit
back and relax and just go with it right
I mean this is the most ex machina of
all the ex machina is really and that's
saying something help will always be
given at Hogwarts Harry to those who ask
first unless your Harry Potter in the
first seven movies of course
well sorry my not so humble opinion I
must say AuSable sauce with magic you
mispronounce frustration dead Voldemort
can't tell when he's being lied to by
anyone in this entire series
Neville runs by the cause of all the
problems in these movies and doesn't
immediately destroy it oh I see Hagrid
was kept alive so this dramatic carrying
Harry's body scene had more impact
that's stupid why isn't this asshole
3000mah Harry Potter is dead Voldemort
at the improv we can find a place for
you in our reign I'd like to say
something Baltimore to allows this still
with us and here Baltimore continues to
allow this Neville brings a sword to a
magic fight Baltimore doesn't go into a
rage smoke monster and track down Harry
Potter immediately like he did in part
one when he got caught in the stupid
power lines later we see him do this
so why couldn't
appear directly in front of him and a
vada cadaver his ass there's a basilisk
Fang so why did he tell Dumbledore he
had nothing to kill the last Horcrux
with the snake still alive and odd
nothing to kill it with man let's look
at one just won't obey Voldemort will it
oh look more wands crossing streams I'll
start with that I'm working my way up to
more dangerous things but you get the
point
not my Dolce issue Thanks this line
combines one of the best lines from
aliens with the awkward title of that
Sally Field movie not without my
daughter only without the without
Bellatrix suffers from the laughing fits
that occur when you're doing battle at
the end of a movie in series lead scene
includes the part where the mice eat all
the pieces and then the cat scene all
the mice director said that's overkill
also mama Weasley so easily dispatches
Bellatrix that are not sure whether to
be impressed with mama Weasley or
disappointed at the supposedly
historically badass Bellatrix also Molly
knows there's an audience clapping right
now so she properly stops the movie to
gloat over her kill all the Mort ignores
the killing curse in favor of a good
old-fashioned magical fistfight it's
like he got 7.5 movies of a decent magic
series that ultimately inexplicably goes
with the Shanghai Knights ending daf
this movie is going to tell me after all
that bullsh but we've seen that wands
are once again crucial for performing
magic isn't there at least a zap my wand
to my hand spell Harry and Voldemort set
a bad example on how to celebrate
Christmas also I feel like I've seen
this before
puncher where I can't quite place it
Neville ex machina or is it Longbottom
ex machina whatever sounds dumber ball
to post more and the unlikely romantic
pairings continue the one never belong
to snipe it was Draco who disarmed
Dumbledore that night in the Astronomy
tower from that moment on the wand
answered him until the other night when
I disarmed Draco and somehow this one
decided to obey Voldemort and put me in
limbo when he shot me with it
but bygones Harry does the right thing
also yeah I get it absolute power
corrupts absolutely and all that but we
never really saw what this wand could do
or that it had some allure that
inherently caused evil and I'm still
trying to figure out the rules of
Wallens and we're nearly done with this
movie skips over Voldemort's two
resurrections to go straight to the
happy ending not terrible 19 years later
make up I still don't believe nobody
ever sees this come I tease kids are a
reminder that Hermione and Ron had sex
at least twice dad 19 years after their
folly was exposed Hogwarts still
separates kids into four distinct groups
so that the hate can continue what is
fine
but instead of Albus Severus supporter
oh my god what's worse the actual name
of this child or the stilted
expositional way it's jammed into the
scene with 12 more minutes accredits I
think you could create an entire movies
worth of credits with these eight movies
I need to get into Gringotts into one of
the votes and there's still the
Declaration of Independence
[Music]
yeah that's a cup of a carpenter
we'll cross the streams
excuse me Egon you said crossing the
streams was bad Ross the streams
you're gonna endanger us you're gonna
injure our client the nice lady who paid
us in advance before she became a dog
there can be only one
now our operation is small but there's a
lot of potential for aggressive
expansion so which of you fine gentlemen
would like to join our team